[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp la seule
émission qui allie alimentation
agriculture écologie environnement est
aussi un peu politique cette semaine
nous recevons laurent berger c'est vous
qui allez passer sur le grill est avec
moi pour présenter cette émission jean
pierre montanay bonjour jean pierre
bonjour brigitte bonjour laurent berger
bonjour bonjour laurent berger vous êtes
secrétaire général de la cfdt depuis
2012 après la démission de françois
chérèque en 2014 et en 2018 vous avez
été réélu avec un score stalinien 90 à
98 % des voix en 2018 vous revendiquer
la place de premier syndicat en france
public et privé confondus une place
occupée jusqu'ici par là si j'étais
alors depuis 2010 9 vous présidez aussi
la confédération européenne des
syndicats fort de tous ses succès vous
vous porterez candidat à votre propre
succession en juin prochain il faut dire
que vous avez le syndicalisme dans le
sont forgés à la jeunesse ouvrière
chrétienne mais votre plus grand combat
est peut être devant vous la réforme des
retraites bête noire des partenaires
sociaux qui vise à porter l'âge de
départ à 64 65 ans tu sais plus très
bien mais pour vous c'est déjà trop trop
c'est trop alors pour cela il vous
faudra des protéines comme la peste le
menu du jeu en espagne en terre oui avec
au menu viande rouge avec un faux filet
bordelaise accompagné d'aubergines et de
tomates confites et en dessert tarte au
citron dans le dos ou des plats les prix
alimentaires flambent
nos astuces pour réduire de 20 à 30%
sont pleins de courses dans les pieds
dans le plat la course aux saisonniers
pour les agriculteurs histoire de
pallier la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
locale dans les champs allez on passe à
table tout de suite cuisine et
confidences
[Musique]
laurent berger vous nous avez demandé de
la viande et à notre question légitime
quelle viande vous avez répondu sans
hésitation rouge et pour la sauce c'est
encore du rouge avec une bordelaise qui
comme son nom l'indiqué est confectionné
avec du vin rouge voilà le ton plutôt la
couleur est donnée et en y réfléchissant
ce n'est pas très étonnant le rouge est
une couleur qui vous obsède de rang
berger et tous les psys de comptoir le
dise notre assiette est le révélateur de
nos fixette et oui d'un côté le rouge
c'est la couleur du syndicat concurrent
de la cfdt la cgt de martinez plus
radicale qui vous fait passer parfois
pour un mollasson donc c'est votre
cauchemar et le rouge de l'autre c'est
la couleur des lignes que vous fixez
régulièrement au gouvernement et à une
manuelle macron retraite à 65 ans non à
ne pas dépasser ligne rouge alors le
temps d'un déjeuner mettez de côté les
contraintes de votre taf est faite comme
le rouge encore le communiste épicurien
fabien roussel et profiter de cette
bonne viande saignante sans entrave mais
est ce encore possible aujourd'hui de
manger de la viande sans se faire
étriper laurent berger
oui c'est encore possible si
on le fait avec un certain nombre de
précautions ça veut dire sans doute il
faudra réduire la consommation de la
viande on le sait pour des raisons
environnementales et il faut regarder je
crois les origines les conditions de
transformation etc donc oui c'est encore
possible après vu votre présentation je
mangerai plus jamais un plat de la même
manière lorsqu'il y aura un quelconque
référence au rouge dedans je le retiens
c'est pas très politique il faut que je
fasse attention non non pas du tout moi
en fait j'avais j'avais dit c'était
plutôt un appel en ce sens parce que
c'est ce que j'aime bien aussi cuisiner
en fait donc
j'aime bien cuisiner j'aime bien
cuisiner la viande notamment de boeuf
leboeuf leveaux l'agneau et vous mangez
beaucoup de viande non pas tant que ça
non pas tant que ça mais j'aime bien
manger de la bonne viande dois-je est en
fait j'aime bien ne pas pour moi leur
passer un moment où ça va pas être le
cas aujourd'hui mais où je passe un peu
à autre chose c'est-à-dire où il ya
plutôt de la convivialité alors on
va parler à mais j'ai pas dit la mère
c'est ce que je veux dire c'est que vous
parlera pas de retraite par exemple ah
oui ça va bien c'est sûr qu'on le compte
gouttes en salle se faufilait pour que
vous nous disiez s'il est à votre goût
s'il est pas trop cuit vous aimez
saignant moi j'aime bien saignant
alors live et saignant un prix est donc
ça
j'aime bien l'accompagnement j'adore les
deux petites aubergines alors j'ai dit
oui alors aubergines tomates cerises
grand chose à savoir ça vous intéresse
trois choses à savoir le faux filet
voilà est-ce que c'est un morceau qui
rappelle la forme de l'entrecôte il est
localisé tout contre le filet d'où son
autre nom contre fidèles - percier que
le filet de boeuf il est apprécié pour
sa texture sa texture tendre on le
vérifie ici il est bourré de protéines
c'est ce que disait brigitte et contient
moins de 10% en matières grasses comme
le rhum steak et dalloyau dont beaucoup
de protéines pas trop de gras c'est
plutôt bon pour la santé assurez-vous
laurent berger si vous en faites cuire 1
de le sortir du frigo 30 minutes du
réfrigérateur plus exactement trente
minutes avant la cuisson pour éviter ce
qu'on appelle le choc thermique avec la
viande si elle est trop froide et si
elle rencontre une plaque trop chaude il
y aura un choc thermique qui va un peu
durcir les fibres découper toujours une
tranche épaisse faut compter 2 cm 3 cm
en fait plus et épais meilleur c'est et
si c'est un peu trop fins or à moins de
vous ce sera moins goûteux enfin la
manière la plus simple de le préparer et
la cuisson à la poêle le faire cuire
environ 3 4 minutes de chaque côté dans
l'huile chaude ou le beurre et si vous
le voulez bleus si encore moins que ça
laissez-le après la cuisson reposer
pendant quelques minutes dans du papier
aluminium ou le recouvrait bien comme ça
il va gagner un peu de tendresse et le
faux-filet supporte aussi sachez le le
barbecue et la cuisson au four alors là
est ce que ça vous plaise qu'il est ce
qu'il est bien
il est très bien que ces deux lettres un
peu je vais bien avec une avec ce type
de sow serait vous savez que
c'est une anecdote mais
quand on me demande tu feras quoi après
etc je le dis avec humour parce que
c'est évidemment pas ce que je ferais je
n'en sais rien de ce que je ferai après
syndicalisme est un des métiers que je
trouve passionnant c'est le métier de
boucher à boucher la découpe de la
viande est la découpe de la viande le
fait de voir les éleveurs ouais c'est ça
le fait de savoir de s'intéresser d'où
vient le produit le doubs vient le
produit qu'on propose à la consommation
le côté un peu enfin en tout cas celle
que je fréquente le côté convivial de
voilà et le côté conseille aussi pour
savoir comment cuisiner mois à chaque
fois que j'achète un morceau de viande
pour pouvoir le cuisiner je veux
discuter avec le boucher pour savoir
s'il n'a pas une petite astuce est
souvent il y en a une plutôt sympa quoi
genre m quand vous faites un boeuf
carottes maître du chocolat très noir
avons une cuisson pour déclarer pour lui
donner un peu donc d'autorité à la sauce
voit des choses comme ça et les viandes
mature et vous aimez vous demandez ça
aussi avoue ne pas trop à vous n'avez
pas trop trop fort trop alors vous par
exemple vos plats signature vous avez
dit tout de suite d'emblée j'aime les
les plats en sauce
je crois que vous aimez bien cuisiner si
on vient chez vous avec jean pierre vous
nous faut nous préparer quoi ça dépend
un peu ce que vous aimez mais je prépare
une tournée très ouverts et parer du ve
au noilly prat et la recette et non une
des recettes qui deviennent de ma mère
ma mère était une excellente qu'il avait
traité parce que je voyais et pratique
vous au noyer pattes le loyer est un
alcool non pardon alors même si la
spéciale d alcool
ouais à boire c'est pas voilà mais en
tout cas ça se cuisine bien avec du veau
quoi des échalotes je peux vous faire
j'ai bien faire un boeuf carottes
j'adore ce plat personnellement je peux
vous faire de lui sauté de volaille à la
mangue
c'est le dernier plat que j'ai fait pour
des amis asiatiques n'ont donc si ça
l'est
quelque chose un peu rapide c'était
quand on cuisine ans enfin 2 en début de
soirée rapidement pour des amis contre
deux au travail ça c'est assez rapide
voilà donc des et vous parlez que de
viande alors que moi j'ai vu on en parle
à toute heure vous êtes plutôt est né à
guérande ont plutôt vers le
j'avais un poisson si si si si je fais
du poisson je peux faire delalot pense
pas c'est pas très bon marché à l'autre
mais là de lotte à l'armoricaine
mais c'est plus compliqué à cuisiner le
poisson 1 à la cuisson sont planifiés
pays latins et puis je pars de loin
parce que ma mère de cuisine très bien
et vous avez le temps de cuisiner en
semaine ou fin semaine en semaine ça
peut arriver lorsque mais c'est plus le
plus dur mais c'est plutôt en semaine
d'ailleurs ce qui fait qu'il fait
parfois dire chez moi que c'est un peu
facile je fais le truc un peu un peu
nobles et puis le quotidien c'est
plutôt bon mais j'ai fait on partage
quand même évidemment non je suis ici
j'essaie de cuisine il ya des plaques
ayant pas ok je ne risque jamais qu'un
de mes plats préférés pourtant c'est le
couscous parce que ma femme le cuisine
merveilleusement bien et c'est là ce
mot-là seaway samassa m'impressionne
toujours passé plusieurs fois le tient
de savoir qui était du voyage
ouais ouais et du coup ça c'est un peu
plus dur c'est la semoule parce qu'il
faut la passer à l'avenir la bouille et
comme comme la semoule et c'est un vrai
savoir faire ça c'est un vrai savoir
faire ça je sais par exemple un plat de
famille qu'on peut trouver c'est un plat
de famille d'anniversaire quand une
famille recomposée donc c'est ça si près
de biens non non et puis des habits
aussi et vous aimez les inspirations
étrangères là vous nous parlez plutôt
d'afrique du nord j'aime bien j'aime
bien j'aime bien faire un peu de tajines
j'aime bien j'aime bien j'ai enfin
j'aime bien essayer quoi voilà et j'aime
bien le le la croche sucré salé si c'est
pas trop marqué ou est ce que je veux
dire je suis pas l'eau j'ai pas
forcément le vocabulaire ce soit un
dessin quoi que ce soit un dessert mme
elhady par exemple puisque la mangue
simple plus dur pour moi j'ai plus de
mal à cuisiner et italiens parce que
souvent l'italie c'est quand même la
cuisine à la française qui règne sur le
monde qui n'a pas mangé les pasta et des
pizzas ou
je vais pas je fais pas de pizza on a
une bonne recette de pâtes mais c'est
une de mes filles qui qu'il le fait
qu'il est plutôt les pâtes à la
carbonara et dans ce cas là je serai
mousson crème avec un peu de crème elle
les
aimait ça il faut faire avec les goûts
des uns ni les autres et dans ce cas là
je suis plutôt les deux cuisiniers je
vais la peluche re ah oui il aurait
commis est alors justement ces légumes
vous allez choisir sur le marché vous
aimez ça moi j'adorerais aller au marché
devrait jouer j'adore aller au marché ou
dans les petites rues commerçantes des
produits locaux bio et doucet j'essaye
bio locaux c'est pas toujours le cas
mais il ya aussi les contraintes de
temps qui peuvent arriver avec qui
permettent pas toujours mais non
j'essaye j'adore aller choisir les
produits j'adore aller faire les courses
avant de cuisiner ça n'avait pas de
petit lys qu'elle cueillait exactement
alors soit sur papier soit sur le
téléphone n'est ce pas oublier net mais
est ce que ça peut aussi guider votre
inspiration parce qu'on part soi et des
idées en tête et on va au marché ramener
ce qu'on avait mais là vous tombez
synhorcat échouez vous dis tiens joie
elle a des infos voilà l artichaut
j'aime bien manger les artichauts
achètent pas les faire comme les allées
faire à la romana ou mais j'aime bien
les artichauts
papilles des petits pains
oui mais ça faut savoir
la guillot diat comme le tourner c'est à
dire ce qu'il faut il et font briller
aussi on a beaucoup plus un sacré bon
parce qu'il est 30 dans l'huile chaude à
l'envers c'est cette vie y est c'est
quoi l'avion mais c'est très compliqué
c'est pas facile ailleurs alors on va
voir si vous êtes vraiment incollable
c'est le quiz
alors laurent berger vous avez bien
involontairement donné votre nom à une
petite saucisse sèche qui a révolutionné
la pirogue prochaine
alors se met donc c'est intéressant
c'est de répondre sauriez vous nous dire
si ces affirmations sont vraies le bâton
de berger né en 1983
ouais bravo ouais c'est jean havrais
habitants de haute savoie qui a donné
son image auberger justin bridou
ben vrai parce que nous le sommes pas
ouais ben oui c'est un avis relis
havrais paysans et il est devenu alors
il est mort je crois je ne sais pas j'ai
bossé il est décédé mais c'est lui qui
est qui a qu'a donné le modèle à justin
bridou dans un spot tv de pub qui est un
peu notre génération dont vous avez on y
voit patrick sébastien déguster ce bâton
de berger en imitant paul préboist vrai
ou faux vrai nom un limitait bourvil ah
voilà et le slogan c'est il n'y a pas
d'heure pour en croquer vrai ou faux
pour manger non ouais voilà vous êtes
croyant sa grande mémoire vous regardez
beaucoup la télé alors non pas beaucoup
pourtant mais le bâton de berger cette
époque-là plus à marquer et regarder le
sport parce que patrick sébastien qui
mitent bourvil pour venger sept petites
saucisses cas il fait si bon ça passe
plus non on peut le retrouver ça passe
plus je vous le confirme
alors il ya un détail dans votre bio qui
ne manque pas de sel c'est que vous êtes
né à guérande à côté de saint nazaire
dont vous êtes incollables sur son sur
son trésor alors ces affirmations sont
elles vraies ou fausses à la récolte du
sel remonte à l'âge de bronze oui non
faut l'acheter ou encore l'air de faire
le fer de faire c'est ce sont des moines
qui en l'an mil ont tracé le plan actuel
des salines
je ne sais pas vrai c'est vrai dans les
années 60 le sel a beaucoup souffert de
l'arrivée du réfrigérateur
oui
dans les années 60 moi je suis vraiment
un enfant de garant d'un mets mon oncle
était paludiers en plus de son travail
de maçon jallet l'été sur les salines
ouvrir les petites les petites rigoles
pour pour faire va amener l'eau et mais
j'ai beaucoup de cousins et cousines des
petits cousins de petits cousins et
cousines qui sont pas liées aujourd'hui
professionnel je connais bien pas
forcément l'histoire est très bien le
paysage les balades et tous ces parfaits
savoir faire c'est vrai c'est vrai que
vous le meilleur je suis un peu chauvin
sur cette affaire là oui
je suis un peu chauvin mais j'adore ça
change tout pour moi quand on dit cette
recette à l'effet au sel de guérande
mais c'est vrai dans les années 50-60 le
sel de guérande a connu une petite
dépression petite déprime mais total ont
effectivement les réfrigérateurs sont
arrivés dans les ménages et les gens ne
conservait plus avec moi ma grand mère
faisait des marais mais c'était pour un
tout petit supplément et aux noms dont
je parle quand on allait en vacances
chez eux le matin il partait très tôt
comme maçon il faisait sa une activité
supplémentaire et le le le talent de la
génération qui a pris des
responsabilités dernière qui a développé
le sel c'est d'en faire dans une affaire
d'avoir fait un produit de qualité et
surtout d'avoir partout assuré d'avoir
une vraie logique commerciale par des
gens qui se sont regroupés et c'est une
logique coopérative et un coopérative
est le plus puissant sur sur les marais
et donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de
très fort en terme de c'est au moment où
on s'interroge beaucoup sur notre modèle
agricole comment on pourrait le revoir
et compris le rendre plus coopératif il
ya des
réalisations grandeur nature et la
coopérative des producteurs de sel à
guérande on est on est une
extraordinaire avec je conseille à tous
ceux qui vont aller en vacances par là
et je leur conseille vraiment d'y aller
avec une petite exposition qui s'appelle
terre de sel quelque chose de très bien
fait ils ont vraiment exploiter
des visites sur les marais je les ai
fait avec les enfants moi je les fais
aussi avec avec ma famille allez
directement pour ceux sur leurs marais
parce que il faut pas y aller sans eux
il faut surtout pas croire que c'est un
espace où on peut aller tranquillement
mais parce que ces abîmes mai mais il ya
des très belles visites fait par terre
de sel pour aller sur les marais avec
les enfants qui explique bien le
processus qui est quand même un
processus naturel extraordinaire avec un
bel 3 c'est la fleur de sel alors
justement dernière question et c'est en
2000 le sel de guérande et la fleur de
sel de guérande sont les premiers celle
à obtenir un nid gp alors est ce que
c'est vrai ou est-ce que c'est faux
c'est le premier à avoir une label rouge
et ils ont la belle rouge et je crois
que je crois que c'est vrai alors non
non il faut parce que
non mais c'était la date qui comptait en
fait 7 en 2007 ça a été obtenue en 2012
d'accord mais ils ont ils exportent
partout maintenant ils ont même fait des
voyages avec certains présidents de la
république notamment je me rappel au
japon du temps de jacques chirac que le
responsable de la ddt
de la coopérative avait été un peu
emmené pour pour de faire faire
connaître le sel de guérande maintenant
une réputation mondiale internationale
alors en france vous savez que le repas
occupe une assez large place
particulièrement en politique c'est
souvent là que se nouent les deals que
se fait la petite et la grande histoire
c'est la brève de comptoir
alors laurent berger on vous a demandé
de réfléchir à une anecdote autour d'un
repas est ce qu'on en a une qui vous est
revenue à l'esprit bah franchement et
des politiques peu parce que je déjeune
peu où je dis un peu avec des politiques
dit n'est quasiment jamais sûr que je
considère que voilà genou pas de
relation extraprofessionnelle avec des
gens qui sont mises en terre des repas
travaillant ça peut être pas de travail
c'est arrivé quand je dis que c'est
arrivé parfois dans des réunions de deux
ça peut arriver non mais l'anecdote
c'est tout ça et nous on a une à une
l'instance dirigeante qui s'appelle la
commission exécutive tous les lundis on
déjeune ensemble après avoir travaillé
et c'est toujours là où on se passe les
infos un peu informel est un moment de
convivialité il est d'autres qui me
revient en tête c'est chez moi j'ai
commencé dans cette commission exécutive
c'était françois chérèque que tu es le
responsable et ils font ça chérèque qui
il aimait bien il avait bien les plats
kyi qui tenait quoi c est
donc il y avait souvent des pâtes et du
riz et je me rappelle me faire chambrer
régulièrement par par françois chérèque
parce que à chaque fois je lui disais
mais pas avoir un peu de légumes cd et
me faire me faire allumer mais sinon non
j'ai pas de gpat gpad anecdote
particulière avec des personnalités
connues sur autour des repas
encore une fois parce que j'essaye de
moi j'aime bien fin c'est un moment où
avec ses collègues de travail dossier
certaines choses on dit souvent autour
d'un repas est bien là la discussion se
faire et la négociation c'est pas un
arrangement entre amis la négociation
c'est un véritable exercice de rapport
de force de la part la par la qualité de
ses propositions et la qualité de
persuasion qu'on peut avoir et la
compréhension de son interlocuteur donc
il peut se nouer des relations plus
cordiales mais je tiens à distinguer
ggg jamais je crois pour revendiquer
j'ai jamais obtenu telle ou telle
avancée tel ou tel 6 mans et c'est parce
qu'on aurai
je tiens à ça moi c'est une forme
d'éthique de responsabilité ça veut pas
dire qu'on est forcément froid et si
l'occasion se présente voilà parce que
ça plus rapide mais globalement c'est
pas comme ça mais est-ce que l'assiette
peut pas influencer le moral de l'autre
ou la forme de l'autre et si on lui
donne écho pour négocier quand il ya eu
les longues séances de négociation il
faut toujours penser à un moment donné à
se restaurer il ya des plateaux repas
qui était arrivé moi il ya des plateaux
repas il ya eu différentes dans
l'histoire selon les périodes il ya
différents différentes pratiques mais où
il faut y aller pas tort il ya les
plateaux repas je pense que c'est moi
j'aime bien déjeuné avec avec l'équipe
qui m'entoure avec les gens qui ce
travail parce que c'est aussi un moment
où on se préoccupe de l'as de la santé
du petit dernier de 2,2 comment ça va
sur différentes et la cohésion de votre
c'est quand même un moment moi je tiens
beaucoup à ça y compris en famille nous
on tient beaucoup à dîner de dîner
ensemble et l'arrivée par la plupart de
vos repas en famille c'est quelque chose
auquel vous tenez il ya des exceptions
mais je trouve que le
s'astreindre à ce que l'on puisse au
maximum dîner dîner en famille je trouve
que ça crée sacré sacré de la cohésion
c'est un simon oui c'est aussi le moment
où quand on est dans des villes qui sont
assez trépidant tout ça va vite c'est
aussi le moment où
chacun peut s'exprimer des fois quand il
ya beaucoup d'enfants il faut un peu
mettre un peu de deux prix un peu
d'argent car c'est d'ordre c'est pas non
plus militaire mais il faut il faut
pouvoir que chacun puisse exprimer
surtout quand il ya un petit dernier qui
fait un peu de bruit mais oui mais non
c'est le moment où on prend des
nouvelles de l'école de comment chacun
avec eux vêtus sa journée c'est pas un
vécu sa semaine donc c'est très
important alors on va parler maintenant
de l'inflation qui touche tous les prix
et même ceux de l'alimentaire alors
comment se nourrir correctement quand
les prix flambent et bien c'est le
dessous des plats
[Musique]
promotion date de péremption proches
produits mal calibré toutes les
occasions sont bonnes pour réduire le
coût de son caddie face à l'inflation
des prix des produits alimentaires les
français ont de plus en plus de mal à
faire face alors si certains se serrent
la ceinture et bien d'autres écume les
sites anti gaspi reportage en région
parisienne de marion lefebvre et steven
martens
dans les rayons elle les prix continuent
de s'envoler plus de 6% en avril sur les
produits frais le panier de courses
fesses de plus en plus lourd et il
devient de plus en plus difficile de
faire des économies alors les promotions
c'est toujours toujours bien d'acheter
mais actuellement les promotions à son
plus cher que que et que les prix sans
promotion d'avant donc ça va c'est que
c'est compliqué vas-y c'est avec les
applications qu'on a déjà et je regarde
les promos et je viens faire à mesure
quand je fais les courses pour gagner un
petit peu des sentiers par ci par là la
jeune est pour ça qu on toro et là oui
j'ai des quelques remises que j'ai
gagnés sur sur des produits frais mais
sinon y'a pas j'ai pas de vie pas de
l'étagé pas de viande et de poisson vous
vous rendez compte pour 3 jours ça
compte en rouge tout c'est énorme c'est
très cher pour faire baisser le montant
du ticket de caisse un couple a eu
l'idée de créer un site anti crise point
fr il recense tous les catalogues
promotionnels des enseignes mais aussi
des coupons de réduction leurs premiers
conseils pour économiser c'est d'acheter
au bon moment ça va vous prendre comme
je vous ai une petite heure par semaine
vous allez dans l'enseigne qui va
proposer des promotions les plus
intéressantes pas forcément votre ancien
des rituels et aussi pas forcément
privilégié une marque d'aucune autre
faut être opportuniste de ce côté là
déjà bien qu'en faisant cette démarche
en changer un petit peu ses habitudes de
consommation jeudi on peut facilement
arriver à
un bon 50 % sur son budget pour soigner
des produits de qualité à moindre coût
c'est la promesse d épicerie nous anti
gaspi et ce tout en luttant contre le
gaspillage alimentaire à l'ats par
exemple ça c'est un premier qui a un
petit problème de g az aspects donc vous
voyez des légèrement affaissés ici et ça
c'est suffisant pour être refusée la
distribution traditionnelle parce que
nos producteurs ont des cas des charges
très strict avec les distributeurs et
donc non lui rachète un prix 20 à 30%
moins cher qu'un coulommiers normal et
on revend client va apprendre pour sont
moins chers que l'outil retrouvant c'est
une solution pour s'alimenter avec des
produits de qualité est vendu moins cher
ce que notre propos n'est pas de vendre
des produits
les plus bas de gamme possible au prix
le plus bas mais les plutôt d'essayer de
valoriser du travail et un savoir-faire
intéressant de la part des producteurs
ce client voit clairement la différence
sur son ticket de caisse
katia ou que voilà c'est ça que 50
certainement dans une surface
depuis que les prix ont bondi de plus en
plus de consommateurs font attention à
leur budget courses dans la grande
distribution
on s'attend à davantage de chasse aux
promotions
alors laurent berger on le voit dans ce
reportage c'est assez difficile pour
certains de joindre les deux bouts ya le
système d les astuces pour réduire un
peu le prix du duc a dit est ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin pour aider les
familles modestes et qu'est ce que vous
proposez oui il faut aller plus loin
pour aider les familles modestes faut
aller plus loin aussi pour aider les
familles en situation de pauvreté on a
réussi à le faire pendant la période de
confinement et la
l'inflation mais des gens dans des
situations intenables et donc on le voit
d'ailleurs les fils alimentaire de
distribution alimentaire progresse donc
il faut aider les associations à faire
ce travail là il faut une aide à la
consommation pour les ménages les plus
modestes échec alimentation là que
propose le président de la république en
tout cas il faudrait je pense que c'est
fait ça vous paraît être une bonne
formule parce que moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que les aides soient ciblées parce
qu'autrement on va arroser le sable
l'inflation le problème de l'inflation
et des difficultés du pouvoir d'achat
moi j'appelle ça le pouvoir de vivre
décemment eh bien ils touchent pas de
l'inflation ça touche pas tout le monde
de la même manière faut pas qu'on se
raconte disparaît des gens qui boite les
prix augmentent si ils sont attentifs
mais pour qui ça ne changera pas
véritablement les la possibilité
d'alimenter ont choisi lundi vous savez
ils y reviennent référence le salaire
médian par exemple si vous êtes en
dessous si vous êtes au dessus ça peut
être une bonne
une bonne façon de faire les 50% de la
population qui en dessous du salaire
médian eh bien on peut on peut on peut
l'aider par à chaque alimentaire je
crois qu'il faut faire des choses moi je
pense qu'il faut dans cette période de
revenir alors pas un euro dans les
restaurants universitaires
avec des aides supplémentaires il faut
sur les ménages et plus beau des jolies
dit mais le pouvoir d'achat c'est aussi
ce qu'on reçoit c'est à dire dans son
salaire ou dans la prestation sociale
qu'on reçoit aujourd'hui par exemple les
minima sociaux pour parler des personnes
en situation de pauvreté les minimales
le rsa n'a pas été revalorisé depuis
donc vous vous demander une
revalorisation
en fonction de l'inflation oui bien sûr
bien sûr il faut il faut le revaloriser
ça a été annoncé dans la campagne mais
on attend de voir ce qui sera fait
et puis il faut revaloriser il faut
revaloriser oui bien sûr mais justement
la revalorisation du smic et et
bienvenue tout le monde se fout de tout
les smic vous j'ai l'impression vous dit
c'est pas le problème n'y a pas que le
sang moi je dis que y'a pas que sigma
qui compte vous savez la revalorisation
du smic
elle entraîne qu'aujourd'hui hasson 43
ou 144 branche a bien entendu 144 244
sur les 171 de plus de 5000 salariés qui
ont des minima en dessous du smic et
c'est vrai aussi dans les fonctions
publiques dans les fonctions vie il faut
savoir que si vous êtes agents de
catégorie c c'est à dire la plus basse
catégorie dans la fonction publique
territoriale vous êtes 11 ans mick
tellement les échelons sont à saisir que
le taux horaire du pas au smi le taux
horaire n'est pas au smic mais il ya une
indemnité compensatoire mais si vous
gravissez théâtre est ravi c'est un
échelon parce que vous avez de
l'expérience parce que vous faites vous
avez un peu de responsabilité et c'est
pas un échelon 2 et chant 3 et 11 ans 11
ans au smic donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
pas même pas de motivation finalement au
travail et il ya surtout un
appauvrissement globale du travail pas
revaloriser le smic non plus apple cette
année justement l'heure pas des excuses
bel avantage du smic c'est qu'il est
revalorisé automatiquement sur
l'inflation sur l'inflation et il
faudrait juste un coup nous ce qu'on
demande c'est que indexées sur
l'inflation dont il faudrait que aucune
grille ne puisse démarrer en dessous du
smic et donc nous ce qu'on dit aux
gouvernants le smic soit pour vous
combien confond bien qu'on comprenne
bien c'est le plancher à ce moment là le
smic c'est historiquement le salaire
d'embauché pour perdre quelqu'un de peu
ou pas qualifiés donc c'est forcément le
plancher et on peut pas y rester toute
sa vie et donc
l'état quel levier pour cela l'état il a
le levier qu'il verse des autres d'aider
des aides aux entreprises ou qu'il
allège les cotisations des entreprises
et bien il faudrait que des carreaux
valorisation du smic est les trois mois
pour se mettre en conformité par la
négociation pour relever les
classifications à défaut de quoi elle
aurait une baisse de leurs allégements
de cotisations faire en gros on
conditionnerait les aides publiques
versées aux entreprises à travers pour
qu'elle soit juste dire que de plus en
plus il faut qu'on se dise que il faut
que les aides qu'ils soient perçus en
entreprise et la série tv pas contre
nous avons souvent sous dispositif d
aide pour que que ce soit une
contrepartie et soit conditionnée au
fait qu'il y ait et sur la question des
salariés à la question sociale mais
aussi sur la question environnementale
d'ailleurs on pourrait revenir il y a
des formes de conditions gagnantes pour
les arrêterons de gagnant pour les
scénarii oui parce qu'autrement où vous
voyez là on a un appauvrissement du
monde du travail on va pas se raconter
d'histoires de ceux et celles qui ont
tenu la baraque pendant la crise coheed
ses salariés quels sont les salariés
qui qui aujourd'hui sont les premiers à
l'insee les deuxièmes lignes on a appelé
ça les deuxièmes ce que les premières
lignes étant évidemment les soignantes
alliant donc il ya un vrai problème
aussi de pouvoir d'achat pour certain
nombre d'entre eux mais ce sont les
personnes qui seraient dans
l'alimentation dans l'agroalimentaire
qui travaillent dans dans la
distribution etc et de la propreté dans
la sécurité et cela est celle là surtout
celle là d'ailleurs entre nous ce qui
dit peut-être pourquoi les re valorise
pas ce sont majoritairement des femmes
eh bien elles elles sont paupérisée
parce que leurs salaires n'augmentent
pas parce que les grilles sont
inférieurs on n'a pas si on avait du
pain sur la table je vous prendrai le
président va voyager il ya une
négociation salariale qui s'est opéré
dans les boulangeries eh bien il n'y a
pas de ya pas de revalorisations
accordées par l'employeur serre que
l'inflation la prend en pleine figure et
gaza sont salariales ne suivent pas
tous les salaires sur l'inflation
c'était le cas vrai nom parce que
j'avais pas dans l'économie des régions
les scores sont juste au dessus du smic
et qu'on a 4 5 6 % d'inflation c'est
difficile aussi même si oui bien sûr et
c'est pour ça mais cela il dit cela
souffrent les bien sûr mais cela
bénéficierait de la revalorisation des
classifications les allégements de
cotisations c'est jusqu'à 1,6 fois le
smic c'est très important cela sont
évidemment tout ce qu'on régule 6 fois
le smic sont pas des choses qui sont
riches c'est pas le sujet et cela ils
doivent aussi avoir des revalorisations
salariales et pour ça les entreprises
aujourd'hui à deux types en fait il ya
celles qui créent de la richesse
beaucoup et il y en a beaucoup qui fait
la richesse qu'on a qu'à regarder ce qui
a été versé comme dividendes en 2021 par
rapport aux années précédentes celle ci
il faut qu'elle entre dans une logique
de répartition de la valeur c'est-à-dire
à équivalence des dividendes versés aux
actionnaires
un retour aux salariés au même niveau ça
s'est passé le cas selon deepak
intéressement ma classe il va sonner
certaines entreprises notamment de la
grande distribution c'est pas du tout le
cas pas du tout cas c'est vrai c'est pas
de la dent d'hérens en ont les moyens ça
je vous parle de celle qu'en ont les
moyens qu'il faut des marseillais qui
ont décidé
qu'ils démarrent moyenne justement je
voudrais du mal sous fait la distinction
celle qui dirige ce qui qui dégagent des
marges de fortes marges et qui
redistribue pas et qui font beaucoup de
mal à la réflexion autour de ce sujet là
et puis il ya les entreprises qui
dégagent peu de marge pourquoi il en
dégage peu parfois parce qu'elles sont
soumises à des marchés publics ou privés
elles sont à la sous-traitance et on
leur serre le cou
celles qui sont dans des situations plus
compliquées donc là il ya deux cas de
figure celle que pour pour celles qui
sont dans les marchés publics et prier
bouddha mans falloir qu'on y parle de le
partage de la valeur sur l'ensemble de
la chaîne de valeur si vous faites la
sécurité sur un site industriel la
restauration collective sur un site
industriel
ou sur un site touristique j'étais un
peu avec les salariés de sodexo la
restauration collective qui sont sur le
site de disney eh bien vous ce serait
pas anormal que vous ayez une partie de
la richesse créée sur l'entreprise et
nook de donneuses d'ordre est simple et
métiers des négociations ça fait partie
d'abord des choses qu'on développe en
termes de pratiques syndicales pour nos
équipes et ça fait des choses partie des
choses que l'on que l'on porte moi ça
m'est venue cette idée et pas que moi à
d'autres pour le site cet industriel de
saint nazaire quand un paquebot au sort
ou un autre un autre navire m'enfin en
ce moment c'est des paquebots quand un
paquebot sort l'intéressement de la
participation c'est pour les 2000
salariés des chantiers mais derrière
derrière tous les sous du réveillon 2010
par milliers de salariés qui sont sous
traitants et qui n'ont pas exactement la
même répartition et donc le problème ce
n'est pas que ceux des chantiers de
touche c'est que ceux des autres ne
touche pas donc il ya des choses sur le
marché public les collectivités
territoriales ou les coller les
collectivités lorsqu'elle passe des
marchés elle devrait s'intéresser à
l'impact social de la signature quelque
est la pause et c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai pour tous il peut y avoir une
oreille bienveillante du gouvernement
oui je crois on essaye de pousser ça
aussi au niveau européen sont d'autres
registres on parle beaucoup du
des aides de la pac et la pac est
absolument nécessaire nous on plaide
beaucoup pour la conditionnalité de la
pac a des impacts à des impératifs
sociaux et environnementaux mais
notamment sociales vous savez nous notre
grand slogan ce moment c'est du social
de notre assiette notre fédération agri
agro alimentaire agriculture à gré à gré
elle dit son truc c'est il faut du
social dans l'assiette effectivement il
faut du social dans l'assiette ifo de
l'environnemental les choses ont
commencé à progresser ses souhaits pour
le consommateur et avoir du social dans
la tête ça veut souvent dire une
addition un peu d'abord le consommateur
est un travailleur potentiel
et ça veut dire plus ça veut dire c'est
plus cher ou un peu moins de marque du
côté des actionnaires et une à un
rééquilibrage encore une fois de la
valeur créée dans l'entreprise et puis
je crois qu'il faut qu'on sache fargo
vers où on veut aller enfin c'est tout
ça est un système global d'une certaine
manière dans les échanges commerciaux il
faut les clauses miroir si nous imposons
des impératifs sociaux et
environnementaux il faut les imposer à
nos partenaires commerciaux ça je crois
que l'europe doit beaucoup à d'autres
commencent à réfléchir à ça avance mais
ça avance mais aller de façon plus
rapide et plus vite et plus forte sur
cet aspect là ensuite il ya la question
de qui et c'est quoi ce qu'on consomme
c'est vrai pour l'alimentation c'est
vrai pour d'autres produits c'est quoi
les conditions de d'élaboration de pour
l'agriculteur mais entre temps entre
l'agriculteur et le consommateur il ya
souvent un transformateur qu'un ouvrier
aux ouvrières de l'agroalimentaire ça
nécessite quand même qu'on s'interroge
sur la façon dont les choses se passent
en termes salariale en termes de
conditions de travail c est tout ça
c'est comme ça qu'a commencé et après
les citoyens c'est vrai il ya une
question d' alimente de de capacité à
consommer
des produits de bonne qualité mais il
faut qu'on s'assure règle aussi par la
répartition de la richesse et puis je
crois sinon il ya une autre solution
c'est la prime macro emmanuel macron
propose de la tripler cherche pas la
prime macron ça c'est bien quand même
franchement
jamais un sadique le syndicat juge que
je suis qui crachera sur l'idée que les
salariés puissent avoir une prime mais
la prime n'a été versée l'année dernière
à peu de salariés et là où on nous
annonçait m il l a été en moyenne de 500
donc c'est à la bonne volonté de
l'employeur plus salée et et et si vous
voulez au bout d'un mois falloir va
falloir se dire qu'il ya un peu plus de
contraintes très d'employeurs et la
contrainte elle s'exerce par la
conditionnalité des aides publiques et
puis elle co s'exerce par là un appel à
la responsabilité des employeurs dans
les entreprises pour répartir autrement
les richesses créées et pour lorsqu'il
ya peu de richesses créées oui moi j'ai
pas dogmatique et bien pour qu'il ya des
dispositifs exceptionnels de type prime
pour faire passer le cap de l'inflation
on est à 4,8 on sait tous que ça nous
touche pas de la même manière parce que
l'énergie ont la pêche tout aille tous
au même niveau et l'alimentation pareil
mais lorsque vous avez un haut revenu
c'est pas pareil que vous fait un bas
revenu donc il a en a un moment un gap a
passé quatre buts il va falloir aider
les ménages parce que si on ne le fait
pas il ya des gens qui vont se retrouver
dans l'embarras non seulement de devoir
faire très attention il y en a beaucoup
qui font très attention mais qui vont
pour pouvoir se nourrir correctement est
ce que vous êtes inquiet peut en amour
pour l'avenir parce que des experts
disent qu'on n'a rien vu encore en
termes d'inflation que ça va exploser
que ça va être énorme est-ce que ce que
oui enfin regarder ce qui se passe sur
deux aspects le côté énergie sur
l'énergie je crois qu'on n'a pas encore
vu réellement l'impact parce que on va
voir comment le conflit l'agression
russe en ukraine se poursuit mais ou pas
mais là il ya un impact donc sur les
prix de l'énergie concept en octobre
novembre il va commencer à penser qu'il
faut quand il réchauffe et ses
habitations on va avoir un vrai problème
et puis sur les produits alimentaires
il y à il y a un problème sur le blé qui
va arriver très très vite qui est déjà
là il ya un problème sur les sur un
certain nombre d'entrants qui permettent
de présenter pour les anglais donc là
oui je pense que ça va c'est un peu ça
peut aller beaucoup plus mal c'est pas
je ne souhaite pas évidemment mais dans
ce cas là il faut anticiper en disant il
faut accompagner la la population alors
j'en passe et à présent à un tout autre
sujet on va parler la main d'oeuvre
étrangère dans l'agriculture qui est
assez nombreuses alors est elle
indispensable et l employé à sa juste
valeur
on en parle et on met les pieds dans le
plat
alors brigitte 1 que ce soit pour le
ramassage des fraises ou le désherbage
des récoltes bio c'est la course aux
saisonniers pour les agriculteurs mais
faute de main d'oeuvre locale il faut
souvent employer du personnel à
l'étranger comme c'est le cas dans cette
ferme la ferme de la motte dont le loir
et cher c'est un reportage d'hélène
bonduelle et d'antoine coutin
ici et maintenant la palette des
herbages la pythie mounir al ahmar tour
parce que tu es la bio ici pas de
pesticides pour désherber
tout se fait à la main les ouvriers en
barque sur ses bons couché à quelques
centimètres du sol
une drôle de machine qui leur évite
d'être courbet toute la journée pendant
qu'il traque la moindre mauvaise herbe
par exemple celle là
celle là avec les couteaux c'est l'autre
comme carotte betterave rouge tout au
tout
mais qu'une fois c'était difficile parce
que le peuple la journée nous rester
comme ça mais j'adore le travail d'un
achat chaire mines vient même de
bulgarie chaque année depuis douze ans
comme saisonnière sur 300 salariés la
ferme de la motte emploie 40 à 60
travailleurs étrangers principalement
des bulgares et des roumains moi j'aime
bien travailler la france parce que
c'est bien
prc sur rogers a ici cdp des chevaux 3.6
maintenant attention la regarderai ce
n'est pas bien c'est pas bien arraché
mais là à oui c'est sûr c'est ce roi tu
fais tu fais un petit peu sur celui là
ok d'accord très bien l'avantagé de ces
personnes c'est qu'ils sont issus du
milieu rural dont ils ont ils
travaillent dans les champs depuis le
plus jeune âge depuis depuis quatre ans
l'âge de quatorze ans dont pour eux déjà
ils savent ce que c'est que travailler
dans les champs le soleil travailler
baisser tout ça c'est beaucoup plus
facile pour eux que des personnes
françaises qui n'ont jamais travaillé
dans les champs qui n'ont pas
l'endurance et peut-être aussi un peu la
volonté pour travailler dans les gens
car c'est bien la difficulté pour cette
ferme qui produit 30 mille tonnes de
condiments et légumes par an trouver de
la main d'oeuvre en france
d'ailleurs ici le chef d'équipé le seul
à parler français je regarde derrière si
vous en oubliez pas attention
ce n'est pas faute d'avoir cherché des
salariés français la responsable des
ressources humaines a même organisé des
rencontres avec pôle emploi son succès
passée l'annoncé via pôle emploi on a
reçu une dizaine de personnes qu'on a
reçues ensemble on a expliqué
l'entreprise on était dans les champs
pour rencontrer comment on travaille
pour bien montrer qu'il soit bien
conscient de ce qu'il faut faire donc
sur une dizaine de personnes on va dire
qu'il ya quatre cinq personnes qui
restent qui commence
le jour même on peut avoir déjà
désistement lendemain il ya cinq ans
pour cent des personnes qui nous ont
lâchés et au bout d'une semaine on a pu
passer ici les travailleurs étrangers
ont le même statut que les français le
même salaire aussi les mêmes conditions
de travail mais pour les fidéliser la
société à aménager des logements dans le
centre ville et sur la ferme moyennant 7
euros par jour douze personnes sont
installées dans cette maison pendant
plusieurs mois c'est un bien qu'on leur
met à disposition et au moins ils sont
comme chez eux comme à la maison et du
coup ben si les gens sont bien le
quotidien elles sont bien aussi
l'électroménager la vaisselle les draps
les lui a failli à tous vraiment c'est
une saison complète ils ont juste à
venir avec leurs valises la plupart des
saisonniers étrangers reviennent d'année
en année moyennant une prime à présent
ce sont même eux qui recrutent
directement leurs collègues dans leur
pays d'origine
laurent berger un reportage édifiant
avec une question sans ouvrier agricole
étranger ce qu' il n'y a plus de
production agricole française en tous
les cas on peut se poser la question car
dans ce reportage bah c'est sûr que
healy a besoin
d' appel à la main d'oeuvre étrangère on
le sait depuis a besoin d'être étrangère
pour faire tourner et l'agriculture en
tout cas si vous mettez à la place de 30
secondes de sept de ses producteurs ils
ont besoin seul truc c'est que vous le
faire faut le faire correctement alors
on a eu beaucoup une période où dans la
grotte dans l'agriculture qui avait des
travailleurs détachés avec il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup d'abus et depuis la
directive qui a renforcé les droits de
ces travailleurs on est davantage dans l
embauche d embauche directe mais ils ont
pas l'air exploiter il ya une crise on
bien alors ça pour une fois logé web est
enfin là on est dans une réalisation
positif tant mieux nous on constate des
fois beaucoup d'abus ou là des campagnes
en direction des travailleurs
saisonniers parfois des abus des
difficultés de logement des difficultés
de conditions de travail qu'ils sont le
travail sont pas là ils sont très bonnes
mais c'est vrai que ça existe oui elles
sont très bonnes vous avez raison et
elles sont en tout cas elles sont
encadrées mais vous savez si on parlait
de la difficulté de recrutement et la
personne qui s'occupe des ressources
humaines drh dit
c'est difficile de rester mais vous avez
vu les conditions quand même c'est pas
c'est pas totalement simple ça m'a
appelé plusieurs plusieurs réflexions
votre reportage c'est d'abord moi je
pense qu'il faut qu'on aille vers le bio
de façon beaucoup plus déterminés à
violeur et berio le bio c'est ça aussi
c'est désormais à la main sont zerbo jeu
faut qu'on aille vers le bio essai
smashing 9 déterminer mais il faut qu'on
ait conscience de ce que ça veut dire
revenir la question sociale ça veut dire
que la question sociale dans vous allez
lorsque vous mettez des engrais la
question sociale des travailleurs âgés
que l'agriculture est peut être posée
aussi la question c'est comment le on le
fait donc vous savez là est ce que dit
pas votre reportage chez les pauses la
façon dont on peut varier et c'est
peut-être pas ça toute la journée et
c'est ça qu'il faut savoir donc il faut
mettre du dialogue social autour d'eux
des conditions d'exercice et il faut
avoir un objectif de social dans
l'assiette c'est à dire qu'en gros le
bio c'est bien ou de façon
environnementale mais tout avance à pose
la même question que pour le non bio 2
comment sont traités les travailleurs
qui à un moment donné on produit le bien
où l'on transformé et ça c'est aimer
mais une des difficultés de recrutement
oui c'est les conditions d'exercice de
ces métiers là qu'est ce que ça fait de
notre pays qu'on n'arrive pas à recruter
des français d main d'oeuvre locale pour
faire ces travaux qui sont certes dur
mais pas ça ça veut dire qu'il ya eu un
gros problème de dégradation de ces
métiers là dans l'image globale et que
cette dégradation aller parfois parce
qu'il ya une image mais parfois parce
qu'il ya des réalités dures car il ya eu
j'étais quand j'étais responsable non
mais je serai pas dans les généralités
de cet ordre là il ya aussi deux
travailleurs français dans l'agriculture
nous on a beaucoup de représentants ces
cultures on est la première d sont dans
le champ professionnel elle le dit quand
même là la drh des français respect
après vous savez on est dans un moment
où l'attendait le marché du travail
comme on dit tendu et bien sûr il ya
plus de plus de travail qu'auparavant
enfin même s'il est encore 5,5 millions
de demandeurs d'emploi donc c'est aussi
ça ces efforts-là de formation
d'accompagnement de valorisation de
valorisation de ses métiers la
valorisation impasse vous le savez un
par les conditions de travail par là et
le salaire par aussi la reconnaissance
qu'on peut avoir lorsqu'on les
travailleurs de l'agriculture donc il ya
beaucoup de travail à faire là dessus il
ya des négociations dans toutes ses
branches là avec souvent la fnsea et
petit à petit on progresse moi je suis
tous les ans au salon en agriculture
tous les ans jeudi à christiane lambert
un patron greffe et cela il faut avancer
sur la question sociale parce que c'est
comme ça que vous arriverez à restaurer
l'image d'une certaine manière et vous
pensez que les salaires on l'a vu avec
brigitte on fait souvent aussi dans la
restauration les salaires ont augmenté
de 20 pour son augmente encore les
salaires il ya toujours une pénurie de
main d'oeuvre vous pensez que si on
donnait directement 20% de plus d'avoir
à les augmenter dans le terreau dicateur
restauration il ya eu un accord à 16%
oui mais et qu'il était un rattrapage de
vous savez mais après la ligue en
battant leurs jeunes agriculteurs pour
cent les salaires restent extrêmement
bas oui donc mais est-ce que sur vos
amis que vous venez d'en bossa permettra
de vous avez dans notre pays il va
falloir toujours se s'interroger sur et
a fortiori après après locaux vides où
on a vu ces travailleurs est essentielle
et les travailleurs d'agriculture en
font partie et c'est ce qu'on met nos
priorités en ce sens ça est-ce que c'est
logique que ce soient ces travailleurs
là qu'ils soient bape et peut payer le
salaire nom évoque le monsieur dans le
reportage chez le smic aujourd'hui le
smic horaire
évidemment pour un travailleur bulgare
et c'est the roll daniel 70 les a donc
c'est important il ya des situations
d'exploitation je le dis il ya les
salaires sont pas dit ça malheureusement
on a tous les ans c'est illégal en est
d'accord c'est illégal ont fait
intervenir la justice et en mai et puis
mais mais mais ça pourrait être un peu
plus quand vous voyez les conditions
d'exercice voyez ce que je veux dire
donc c'est tout ça qu'il faut il faut
travailler une question d'attractivité
de filières professionnelles aussi à
construire de deux parcours
professionnel parce qu'on veut peut-être
pas sassou de sa vie sert certainement
pas ça toute sa vie donc il faut cesser
travail ce travail là qui est menée par
notre fédération avec avec les
interlocuteurs patronaux de
l'agriculture pour regarder comment on
progresse mais oui aujourd'hui c'est
clair sur un certain nombre de récoltes
ou deux sur certains secteurs agricoles
sans les travailleurs venus de
l'étranger dont on sait pas faire là on
voit que dans la restauration manque de
cafetiers on manque de deux serveurs
pour cet été justement est-ce qu'il faut
dire à la main d'oeuvre étrangère venez
nous aider parce que sinon il y aura pas
assez de main d'oeuvre y aura pas assez
de pour moi ça se laver et moi je crois
que là d'abord je je fais pas partie de
ceux qui ont peur que eelv fière de
notre pays des gens qui viennent
d'autres pays pour pour y travailler et
y vivre loin s'en faut mais oui il ya
des secteurs où il faut faire venir on
n'a pas c'est pas notre histoire ça on a
connu ça à plusieurs reprises déjà mais
là il ya un besoin nous eh ben
ça veut pas et puis de l'autre côté il
faut qu il faut regarder les garder cinq
millions de personnes pour les intégrer
foley bah oui s'il le souhaite vous
savez je vous parlais des chantiers
navals tout à l'heure il ya des
centaines et des centaines de
travailleurs étrangers sur les chantiers
navals mais il faut aussi se préoccuper
des 5.5 millions de personnes qui
demeurent au chômage et qui bompard
besoin d'un parcours d'accompagnement
pour potentiellement retrouver un emploi
et potentiellement dans ce scénario une
proposition il ya le rsa qui pourrait
être conditionnée à quelques heures de
travail c'est ce qu'a proposé emmanuel
macron pendant la campagne présence à
ces une vision qu yves
pauvreté tout d'abord je vais vous dire
un truc moi j'étais conseiller en
insertion professionnelle vous savez que
ça me passionne déjà discuté de ça
vous voyez la technicité des personnes
qui sont là ils font pareil non il faut
bien ça moi je ne serai pas le faire
il faut pas confondre les mauvaises
herbes avec la plante est bien d'accord
c'est sûr mais vous savez si vous vous
dites parce que tu as le rsa d'abord tu
vas travailler 15 heures c'est à 15h
c'est plus que le rsa donc ça veut dire
que tu travailles là pour le coup c'est
de l' esclavage et et si la personne est
dit mais attendez ce parce que je veux
faire ce pas c'est pas la région où j'ai
envie de vivre c'est house et à ben
prend pas le bon truc vous forcez pas
les gens ça n'existe pas ça et en plus
ça renvoie une image où la personne que
vanessa elle serait prête à travailler
directement aujourd'hui et ce sera de sa
faute c'est pas la réalité concrète les
personnes on a besoin de les accompagner
et donc faut plutôt avoir des logique
d'accompagnement du parcours qui est
parfois pas que professionnel qui en
termes de santé oms terme de frein à
l'emploi qui peuvent exister en nation
de formation des questions de garde
d'enfants extra faut accompagner sa et
permettent aux gens d'aller vers les
emplois qui seraient éventuellement
disponibles si évidemment il le souhaite
on peut pas faire autrement monsieur
bergé la ccdd rom des roumains et des
bulgares donc des européens mais j'ai vu
que dans le même département que celui
qui est citée dans le reportage et des
problèmes des marocains qui sont extra
communautaires et les visas ont été
bloqués donc les ramasseurs de fraises
ont manqué de manoeuvre est ce que cette
pénurie de main d'oeuvre locale peut
influencer la politique migratoire
française pour faire venir ces
révélations est-ce qu'il faut assouplir
oui elle peut l'influencer mais je ne
souhaite pas qu'on ait une politique
migratoire qui se résume à la logique
que d'une seule propres intérêts ce que
je veux dire c'est que oui bien sûr il
peut y avoir des travailleurs qui
viennent d'autres pays parce que il y
aurait des besoins mais la politique
migratoire ne serait pas aux réfugiés
les réfugiés politiques quels qu'ils
soient pas simplement quand ils viennent
d'un pays européen mais aussi d'autres
pays il faut accueillir des bonnes
conditions d'accueil même pour ceux qui
seraient pas dans un mouvement d'asile
mais qui sont aujourd'hui sur notre
territoire fin qui d'entre nous n'est
pas choqué parce qu'on voit quasiment
quotidiennement sur les conditions qui
sont faites aux personnes
migros sans transition à présent on va
passer au dessert c'est le péché mignon
alors le dessert avec un dessert choisi
par laurent berger une tarte au citron
un mot de l'histoire l'art tard ce
citron elle a été inventée par les
quakers ces anglicans rue puritains qui
à la fin du xviiie siècle ont créé
confectionnés et ce dessert cet art est
devenu un classique sous le nom de lemon
paille dans les états du sud et en
californie avant d'être importée en
europe via la suisse alors la grande
question sur la tarte au citron c'est
meringuée ou pas meringuée les deux les
deux mon cadeau reda voilà j'adore ça
vous savez la faire ah non ah non je ne
suis pas bon sur les desserts oui j'suis
pas bon ce n'est pas les recettes
exactement comme les desserts c'est pas
les desserts ça peut pas ça souffre pas
d'un de petites et reprogramme près là
c'est ça et donc je suis pas très douée
sur les desserts et du coup à part les
crêpes et du coup je sais pas faire
surtout si la tarte au citron ses
souvenirs d'enfance et un moule c'est un
groupe j'adore ouais c'est presque
maintenant quand on achète des
pâtisseries il ya toujours une tarte au
citron c'est pour moi est d'ailleurs
assez important non mais dans un d un
déjeuner et récent avec des gens la
famille bach c'est quand vous êtes poli
vous recevez vous dit pas choisi c'est
ce que vous voulez personne ne touche
jamais
compris les mais comme je suis je suis
je suis assez assez poli j'ai laissé
faire je trouve vous êtes très sucré on
va la goutte et la réprobation
voilà problème avec le sucre
faut savoir brigitte que c'est un peu
riches à la tarte au citron parce que
c'est du jus de citron avec beaucoup
beaucoup doc et de beurre pour faire
l'appareil sharif c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de beurre elle est très bon
alors maintenant vous avez des tartes au
citron végétal qui n'ont donc pas de
beurre et qui sont assez convaincante ça
existe aussi sachez le merci beaucoup
laurent berger d'avoir accepté
l'invitation